Cherophobia is the fear of fun.
There are no clocks in Las Vegas gambling
casinos (So you stay longer)
In ancient Egypt, pillows were made of stone.
Golf courses cover 4% of North America.
Squirrels plant thousands of new trees each
year simply by forgetting where they put their
acorns.
The largest snowflake ever recorded reportedly
measured 15 inches across.
Under the reign of Chairman Mao, every Chinese
family was obliged to kill a sparrow a week
to stop them from eating all the rice.
The project was ineffective because sparrows
don't eat rice.
It is physically impossible for pigs to look
up into the sky.
You can tell from the statue of a mounted
horseman how the rider died.
If all four of the horse's feet are on the
ground, he died of natural causes.
One foot raised means he died from wounds
suffered in battle.
Two legs raised means he died in action.
Until the 1960s, the only reliable pregnancy
test was to inject a woman's urine into a
female African clawed frog.
If the woman was pregnant, the frog would
ovulate within 12 hours.
Every day 20 banks are robbed.
The average take is $2,500
When you dream everything and everyone you
see in that dream you have seen or met before
in real life.
Nothing is made up.
There are over 1,200 species of bat in the
world and not one of them is blind.
The word 'school' comes from the ancient Greek
for 'free time'.
Sending a man to the Moon and finding Osama
Bin Laden cost the US government about the
same amount of time and money: ten years and
$100 billion.
Loch Ness is deep enough and long enough to
contain the entire population of the world
ten times over.